there was another sign today of how
difficult reaching that brexit
settlement will be immediately after
visiting a Majesty the Queen to request
the dissolution of Parliament teresa may
accused european politicians of seeking
to influence next month's general
election
whoever wins on the 8th of june will
face one overriding task to get the best
possible deal for this United Kingdom
from brexit and in the last few days we
have seen just how tough these talks are
likely to be Britain's negotiating
position in Europe has been
misrepresented in the Continental Press
the European Commission's negotiating
stance has hardened threats against
Wishon have been issued by European
politicians and officials all of these
ads have been deliberately timed to
affect the result of the general
election that will take place on the 8th
of June well Ally Renison joins us now
live from Brussels she's head of Europe
and trade policy the Institute of
Directors which today called for the
next government to meet the EU in the
spirit of transparent
negotiations Oh Ally it's all getting a
bit ugly I mean how do both sides turn
it down a bit and make it a bit more
conciliatory I think we have to expect
some of this we're going into a general
election so politics or an absolute peak
fever pitch at the moment and we're
really be looking for I think once the
election is over some more clarity and a
little bit more sort of pragmatic talk
from both sides if we have to remember
that both sides sometimes are at fault
for letting people be run by tabloid
headlines and what who says in what
continental or British press so I think
the hope is that once the election is
done and dusted there'll be a lot more
clarity and pragmatic talk from both
sides well as you say Teresa May made
these comments today there are some in
Brussels who do not want these talks to
succeed who do not want Britain to
prosper do you agree or she just turning
up the rhetoric a bit do you think I
mean it's interesting I've been in
Brussels today with a slew of different
businesses from Northern Ireland talking
to a range of different people British
representatives in the European
Parliament European counterparts and I
don't necessarily recognize that but I
think that both sides sometimes talk
past each other you can look at issues
like the financial settlement actually
if we look at what the European
Commission said today it talked about
making sure that there was the principle
of the formula reach not the actual
settlement itself if we look at for
example there's actually some
recognition from both sides about the
fact that citizens rights should be
discussed and settled as soon as
possible
the Northern Ireland border issue etc so
I think sometimes both sides are a bit
guilty of realizing that there actually
there's not that much between the two
sides
I've seen one or two suggestions that
may be a third party should get involved
here and try and inter mediate I've seen
it suggested that the Japanese would be
a good candidate do you think that's
going to gain any traction anywhere I
think that third parties are certainly
already making their representations to
both sides for example the Japanese
government in industry has a clear
objective in making sure that there's
not a massive disruption to trade I
don't think it would be necessarily the
best idea to have one government
adjudicate I think ultimately that you
know in the spirit of international
legal norms this will be a negotiation
between both sides I was reported fairly
recently that the government had here
had taken a lot of legal advice
suggesting that there isn't going to be
a bill to pay
there was a House of Lords subcommittee
fairly recently chaired by Liberal
Democrat remainer
who came to that same conclusion how is
that going to play in Brussels well as
we said that this you know we have to
underline that what the u.s. agreed is
their own respective negotiating mandate
the UK is sometimes not the best at
matching that sort of level of
transparency so I think part of the
uncertainty from all this stems from the
fact that we've had a Bristol of brexit
white paper we've had a great repeal
bill white paper but we need a bit more
clarity from the UK side about the sort
of detailed nature of its objective so
that we understand that where where both
sides are actually coming from the same
positioning point how much of this is
noise from individual EU countries for
their own domestic voters consumption I
mean this is going to blow a big hole in
the EU budget when Britain leaves
countries like Germany the Netherlands
Poland potentially could be financially
out of pocket couldn't they it's
certainly the UK is the second biggest
net contributor to the European budget
so it certainly is a big big potential
black pit although I don't think that's
necessarily what's driving the when it
looks at sort of financial settlements
how the calculation should be derived I
do think though it's interesting that
the House of Lords committee itself came
to the conclusion that there wasn't
necessarily an obligation in and of
itself for the UK to stump up and I
think this goes to the heart of the fact
that we can't really have a complete
separation between the withdrawal
divorce proceedings if you like and a
new framework there has to be some
overlap at some point soon to sort of so
you can understand that basically there
is a lot of trade-offs and coordination
between the two phases of negotiation